la foire de corbigny terrain de campagne
entre les étals patrice perron à la
recherche des voix qui lui permettrait
de confirmer son avance du premier tour
l'occasion parfois de rassurer sur le
programme de la république en marche
vous êtes complètement exonérés de
sécher tout peut s'inverser
vous savez ce jeu suit la biche dans ce
pluvieux politique donc bien évidemment
la vie m'a appris aussi parce que
tellement de choses pourraient se passer
aujourd'hui je les imagine pas quelques
mètres plus loin christian paul et son
équipe entre le député sortant est le
fils de son ancien suppléant la
courtoisie est de mise mais les changes
limiter au strict minimum
ça va très bien l'enjeu du second tour
est bien présent car si le candidat ps
veut conserver son mandat il devra
combler l'écart avec son adversaire en
marche un retard de près de 7000 voix
dimanche dernier on nous avait promis
l'effacement nous avons fait mentir les
sondages au premier tour de cette
élection et j'entends bien faire mentir
aussi les les prédictions pour le second
tour parce que je n'accepte pas l'idée
qu'il y ait une assemblée nationale qui
soit monocolore des candidats d'être aux
portes du morvan le député sortant
conserve encore une bonne cote
mais là aussi l'envi de renouvellement
se fait parfois sentir bon c'est quand
même temps ce qui fait que les ôter son
adversaire il est pas trop connu un donc
marcher d'éviter en un jeune au
gouvernement
chance fossiles et un candidate ça fait
20 ans qu'on voit un peu ras-le-bol
j'ai une petite idée effectivement j'ai
une petite idée je verrai ça dimanche
christian paul espère encore mobilisées
pour décrocher un 5e mandat et préserver
l'héritage socialiste dans la nièvre
mais le défi est de taille pour
renverser la dynamique du premier tour
en faveur de patrice perron et la
république en marche